[Music]
good morning happy Monday so it's still
snowing outside
despite the fact we're in the West
Country it's it's really cold at the
moment but I'm inside and nice and nice
and snug and warm in like two jumpers
and this morning I am going to be doing
my thesis Corrections so RTD of Iver you
are told to change few things in my case
I had a bunch of spelling and grammar
things which is kind of expected it's a
massive document you're bound to mess up
somewhere and then I also was requested
to do a little bit of extra analysis
which really shouldn't take very long I
actually don't have to write any new
computer code to do any analysis I have
to write a little bit to do some plots
but not actually that much left to add
to the thesis now I'll be honest with
you I think this week's gonna be more
representative of what my life has been
like post PhD because last week quite a
lot happened like there are a lot of
different things like you know giving a
tour picks will go came and visited when
sledging this week I think is gonna be
much more me getting my head down
planning ahead getting videos done and
also you know sort of setting stuff up
for the future much as I said earlier
that I was going to be doing thesis
Corrections I actually have spent all
day just replying to emails it has been
astonishing just how much I've typed
these things build up so this is the
grind this is that this is the grind of
just like you know setting stuff up for
the future answering people's questions
and you know eventually today I will get
a chance to do some editing
so I asked you guys on Twitter what I
should be calling this new series before
the first episode comes out and it seems
like Doc now what is winning which I
really like I think that was dr. Lucy
Rogers who suggested that one of Robot
Wars Fame
incidentally bring back Robot Wars so
this new series has a name now it's just
got to be determined whether this is
interesting enough to actually you know
film the way that I see it this is going
to be like a diary of a young
professional basically this is me pretty
nascent in the field and you know I have
been doing YouTube for years I started
in 2010 but I've only now been doing it
full-time really since the start of this
year since the start of 2018 and you
know this is going to be my diary of me
hopefully over the coming episodes
successively getting better and better
and better at it and getting more and
more exciting opportunities and I'm talk
I talked to people today in emails about
you know three or four really exciting
opportunities are coming up there are so
many things planned I can't mention yet
but I'm hopefully going to make four
really interesting vlogs when I go to
these places so the way I see it this
series is like an investment on your
part you can get invested in me now if
you're not already
as a young someone you early in their
career it just so happened that I was
early in my career during the phd vlogs
and I've now moved from science to
science communication and video
production but this will hopefully be a
diary of my incredible success or
potentially crushing failure in which
case you know maybe this will be a
tragedy rather than a comedy but they
both have their merits okay so something
new just happened to me I was just
written about by 1080 which is a
magazine about youtubers in the UK and I
don't think I think I was mentioned in
there before when I won next up last
year but this is the first time I've
ever been in like the weekly summary of
like this is new noteworthy one'd you
i've got like the same billing as Carrie
hope Fletcher and Lex croucher and these
people that I watched when I was like
kind of you know dreaming about making
my own videos kind of kind of nuts I'll
be honest I literally just said you know
this is gonna be hopefully about my
professional development and success
maybe I should start talking about that
more I should get more media attention I
guess it goes to show that whilst you
can have days which are kind of boring
like just doing emails all day
apparently I'm moving in the right
direction that's really that's really
lived in my mood actually thank you 10
80
first gym session of trying to gain some
mass get some games from macros and buy
macros I mean the type found in Excel
we're getting swole through pivot tables
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm a final note from yesterday um some
of you might think yourself where does
this come from you know what are you
doing this I like working out I really
do like going to the gym I think there's
something very scientific about it it's
like if you do this exercise this many
reps and you have this many calories in
this much protein you will see this
response and muscle like it's it's basic
biology I guess so I know there's
there's something appealing about it and
also it's just fun by doing it I have
pretty consistently for the past couple
of years known what to do in the gym I
just never track what I've eaten
properly until last year when I started
losing weight and I'm now about 10 kilos
lighter than I was this time last year
this isn't a sponsored video but I I was
using my fitness power which is a really
really great app I like it I lost 10
kilos it works so for the next three
months this is gonna be a little project
it's not gonna be the whole focus of the
block because I think that'd be quite
boring for a lot of people but it's
gonna be something that I'm doing and
you know if for those of you are
wondering why I'm doing this apart from
you know it's a good opportunity to
basically I like doing things I like
being all to physically do things like
run and jump and climb and you know
I don't like the feeling of being unfit
and part of fitness is cardiovascular
fitness the part that is also strength
it's also your ability to pick stuff up
and move it around I like you know I
like being useful so partly it's a
practical thing I just like be able to
move stuff around but on second modest
I'm gonna look better and I know that
there are good people saying oh but you
never seem to find the way you have some
reason um coke from yeah I'm fine with
the way I look right now especially
after I've lost a lot of fat but I want
to put some muscle on it's my decision
I don't feel pressured to do it I just
want to do it today you go oh yeah got a
haircut by the way
hope you I won't touch my hair so much
in vlogs now alright so I just finished
watching if snows lates video plays be
they don't know basically last night
Alex and I were actually talking about
in the car there was some screenshots
leaked of this really disgusting
conversation happening between some
students in a Law Society at the
University of Exeter
and since they've been leaked the
university's taken action the students
have been suspended there's an
investigation going on between the
student guilt and the university itself
basically the universities jumped on us
immediately
quite rightly in my opinion but
something else that's happened is the
IPPS
has uploaded a video for those of you
that don't know it's is a cambridge
student who previously applies to Exeter
and I'm gonna paraphrase he didn't have
the best of times applying I will let
you watch his video I'll leave a link
down there you can watch his video and
he just published another video about
the University of Exeter
with regards to this incident in that
video he calls me out basically very
respectfully it's gotta be said you know
it's not accusing me of being racist or
anything like that he's he's he's asking
me basically why haven't I talked about
races and x2 in my blogs now I just left
a comment on his video but I wanted to
include a little bit on video to address
his questions so the first thing I want
to point out is that I people seem to
have it wrong that I disagree with lives
on his like video somebody commented on
my video basically saying should I apply
to xDrive heard the people get messed
around I said you know you boys do this
video
in my experience when applied to my PhD
I didn't have any problems basically and
my friends didn't have any problems
weren't applying I'm not I by that I
wasn't trying to demean what has
happened there's no reason to suggest
that he's not telling the truth I
completely believe him you know it's
what I was saying was that based on my
personal experience I didn't see any of
that and that's what I want to kind of
anchor this discussion on because during
my time at Exeter I made bunch of video
blogs and not once that I talked about
racism x2 that is not to say that I
don't think that there is racism x2 in
the same way that there's racism I'm
sure basically every university in the
country there will be a few people at
every institution who has these really
disgusting beliefs and archaic you know
ideas about whether that's white
supremacy or a his sexism or you know
whatever there are always going to be a
few stupid people like that basically I
don't think that's you need to Exeter
equally I'm not saying that it's that
you know that this is definitely
something that happens at Exeter that's
point number one point number two is
that my videos were only ever meant to
be a personal account right the whole
appeal of the blog I think is that this
is my personal journey through doing a
PhD through studying Exeter it's not
ever tried to be this is what it is like
to be a student extant this is what
music is like an ecstatic everyone you
know it was only ever a personal
narrative and so in case you hadn't
noticed I'm a I'm very very white I mean
this lighting doesn't help but I am a
vanilla man and as such because I was a
white dude in a predominantly white
University I didn't personally
experience any issues of racial
discrimination directly I didn't
experience any racial discrimination
personally and equally I didn't have any
friends including students of color they
didn't experience direct racial
discrimination or at least they didn't
talk about it I think that's one of the
issues here is that this as it says in
his video this issue has come about
because people were able to take screen
shots and you know they can present the
proof for this these disgusting things
are being said it becomes
to prove in the modern day basically
that you know these things are happening
and so it may what be that my my friends
had experienced discrimination of one
form or other
they just didn't we didn't talk about it
that is why I didn't bring it up in my
weekly vlogs because it didn't fall
apart of my personal experience of
university now to be very clear about
that
I fully concede that I am a white dude
and I do not see these things clearly
the you know it is basically impossible
for me to have the same experience the
same institution as a student of color
and I completely defer to students of
color who say they're experiencing
discrimination I am not for one second
trying to say that their opinion is
wrong or invalid all that I am trying to
say here is that my personal experience
was of a particular nature however it is
crucially important that we talk about
these issues and I think the difference
between it's basically it just calls me
out saying why didn't you talk about
this in your video and as I said in the
comment my video is a personal right I
deal with stuff using a personal
narrative I set this channel up to help
kids from state schools from low-income
backgrounds to get into walks bridge
because that was my experience
he's his channel because he's a student
of color to talk about these issues
because that's his personal experience I
think if I was to try and talk about
that like in a cup I felt if I were to
try and you know Hackney in a discussion
of you know what it's like to be a
student of color the issues that they're
facing I think that would be hackneyed
and kind of like corny a best basically
if it's worst it would just be offensive
it would it would be completely
inappropriate so I'm not for a minute
saying that these issues don't affect
people because clearly they do what I am
trying to say is that I hadn't talked
about them before because I didn't think
it was appropriate for me to do so given
my experiences and my format and that my
opinion on how x2 is for students of
color I don't mean like I think they
have taken the right steps at the time
of recording they have what they've
suspended the students there's an
investigation going on the gill would
have like jumped on this immediately I
think extras have the right response
this publicly I think they publicly said
look this is the thing
happened let's investigate this which i
think is exactly what they needed to do
I think what's gonna happen next is
going to be interesting if like it what
the university does to try and make sure
this doesn't happen again because it's
one thing to admit publicly that an
event happened it's another thing to
pursue that idea that that conviction
and say look we don't accept this like
is I pretty sure I speak from University
everybody at the University and saying
we don't tolerate this kind of behavior
like it is now a question of what do we
do to make sure it doesn't happen again
[Music]
today's outfit says I work at home but I
have a video call so the first video
calls been done today and there's
actually a few again I think as I
mentioned earlier in the week there's
just a lot of setting up now like it
feels like half of my time is spent sort
of looking at stuff that's gonna happen
in the future rather than making stuff
at the moment I'm currently editing
hopefully the last kind of session and
finishing off the vlog for last week and
getting that out and really desperate to
get this out and then also get to work
on the science video for this week which
I can actually talk about in theory will
be out by the time this box
[Music]
so that's gonna be about faster than
light travel which is something that I
know a fair bit about but obviously it's
one thing to know about a topic and
quite another to write a proper
scientific script about it so a little
bit anxious to get to work on that I
think it's gonna be super interesting to
look back on this series hopefully like
it keeps going and people keep watching
to be honest even if people as long as
this series doesn't damage my channel I
think I'll keep doing it I think it's
gonna be really interesting to look back
and see how my day my day-to-day life
has changes fingers crossed
as the channel becomes more popular and
you know I can start delegate tasks and
you know like just just to see like over
the course of a year how much my
day-to-day life is is changing
[Music]
we've got so much better with their
endings so because it's 2018 I'm able to
watch my old Chapel Choir on my TV
because University of X the Chapel Choir
has started live-streaming their
services and I just cram casted it this
is weird like singing in this choir for
four years and now suddenly I can watch
them on TV
I really miss singing with Chapel Choir
like I haven't done anything musical and
this year like I miss singing basically
fortunately later this year I'm gonna be
going on tour with them to France
fingers crossed and actually later this
week later this vlog for you I'm heading
down to Exeter to catch up with the
choir and also test out some new live
streaming technology oh I'm really proud
of what the group's achieved to make up
to bring culture although I'm now
watching the oxcart stream in Warhammer
because that's just how I roll sometimes
just for a few minutes then I need to
finish off this vlog
[Music]
so the new vlog is out it was released
this morning I finished it off last
night after the watching the warhammer
stream and what I didn't show you I
didn't vlog it was went to the gym with
Alex and then after that I came back and
I finished off the thumbnail not loading
everything but what Alex and I did at
the gym was we were having a discussion
about the what I mentioned on Monday
which was the kind of scandal I guess
it's for a the right word that's come
out of Exeter and what I can do what how
I can use my platform and as I said on
Monday the problem that I have had is
that my channel is limited by being a
personal perspective it's not try to be
anything more than a personal
perspective and I think the best way
that I can use this platform what with
that limitation is to offer it to a new
a different personal perspective so I'm
actually going to x2 this Sunday to do
some stuff at Chapel Choir we're
recording a performance which of course
I'll be bringing you with me when I'm in
Exeter I am going to be sitting down
with a friend of mine who is a BME
student and has been quite active on
Twitter sort of on both sides of the
equation actually retweeting the
University statements on this and also
retweeting statements from students that
feel like this isn't a surprise this is
part of a broader culture so what I'm
going to be doing is on Monday in the
vlog next week I'm going to be sitting
down with her for a couple however long
it is a couple of minutes and offering
her the chance to put her personal
experiences forward and basically back
off and say you know I've I've put my
personal experience at extra across it's
time to allow you to say what you think
I'm just going to ask a couple of
questions and let her experiences do the
talking I realized this isn't something
I have to do people might feel like
perhaps I've been pressured into this
online but I think it is an important
thing to do because this channel was all
about was founded to improve inclusivity
in education it was all about trying to
get state school kids into Oxbridge like
me and this is part of a broader
societal struggle it's about making sure
that people can go to university and
feel welcome and that there's not an
environment being created at university
whereby certain students of a background
of what their background is certain
students of a background do not feel
that they're comfortable so I have a
responsibility with a platform of
founded on that basis and of this size
to continue that work and as I've said
in I had been limited by how I've told
my story in the videos I've been making
so let's try and use this platform for a
broader good that's going to be in the
next vlog in happier news
now that the vlog has come out I can
finally start work on the next science
video which is going to be about how to
go faster than light this is a video
that I've been meaning to make quite a
while so I'm quite excited to get into
it but like the history of Pi video I
don't have very long to do it according
to my schedule it's gonna be out in two
days I'm not sure if it's gonna be out
on Saturday or Sunday we'll see but I
think it's possible but it's going to be
quite a lot of work
[Music]
right now though we've got a very rushed
recording of the new wiki cast this is
two things I do every week now bloody
hell this time is gonna start
disappearing very quickly I can tell
I've cred accredited accredited accredit
it'ld are you having a stroke right why
can't I read that accredited accredited
accredited they pocketed it in Harry
four in no okay so he pocketed it I
can't say it in response to the new vlog
somebody pointed out something which I
thought was quite nice and that's that
if you are subscribed to me
you are one of the people that
contributes to that number number of
people subscribe to the channel so you
watching make sure you're subscribed why
wouldn't you be subscribed by this point
you are in the video in kind of an
abstract way so that was kind of cool so
since finishing up the wiki cast I have
been writing I have been getting on the
bus tonight video it's a little bit
disheartening when you have a great
concept for a video I know this is
something that when I was younger before
I did my physics degree our we've been
interested in this it's a little bit
disheartening to see that other channels
have already made a video on the same
topic it's not the same video because
I'm presenting stuff in a very unique
way it's a personal way of science
communication incorporating things like
prequel memes for example hello and
incorporating it you know it's the way I
think of it it's personal storytelling
I'm telling I'm communicating science as
if I was telling a story when I write a
script and maybe I'll make a video on
this in the future
I you know separate it out into plot
points and key ideas and then make sure
that you follow the therefore or but
rule in the between the key points there
has to be a therefore or a but I'll link
down there a fantastic video by the
sadly now dead every frame a painting
channel that's a great video for sort of
working out how to tell how to tell a
story and that's what I try and do with
science which isn't something which i
think is done very much so it was a
little disheartening to see that people
have already made very similar video
and I think in a way that combined with
sheer tiredness from not really taking a
break for quite a while its kind of
ground me down a bit so late this
afternoon I'm just a bit like yeah
feeling it feeling it a bit doesn't help
that my body is aching from the past tea
gym sessions why do I do this to myself
why why do I keep taking on too many
things I guess that's why a lot of you
watch though mister what you sick
bastards you like watching me put put
myself through all this torture fuel for
your amusement well this is just the way
I am this isn't this isn't a gimmick
this isn't an act as you'll see now I do
vlogs every week this is just who I am i
as somebody commented I come here it was
said I'm glad to see you're still a
working yourself that's kind of the way
I've always been so perhaps I should
take that as a hint and you know take a
little bit of time off sometime soon
maybe it may be a day off would be nice
looking through the comments from the
most recent vlog I want to give a shout
out to sweat sir sweat sweat SWE PC
swept at itis see who suggested doc
comma now what as opposed to don't know
wat which is what the original title was
so that's that's that we tweaked
slightly I could've got away with we've
not even mentioning that but I thought
credit where credit's due
yeah slightly changed the title of the
blog so it makes sense so this morning I
walked down to the shops just to give me
a chance to get outside and to give you
something of a different you know change
the scenery it's not just my office all
the time somebody asked in the comments
of the recent vlog what podcast I
listened to which is a really good
question because I went through a
massive burst of watching watching
listening oh my God my I am so not with
it this morning my ping to the Outernet
is ridiculous so apart from the wiki
cast which of course you should all be
listening to already two podcasts which
I think it's important everybody listens
to are more or less and in our time
they're both by the BBC the BBC radio
also does podcasts more or less is about
statistics and it basically takes
figures and kind of breaks down maybe
you hear something in the news like 75
percent of Britons can't name an author
something like that they'll break that
down
where does this come from are these
assumptions good assumptions what does
this tell us and they do it for things
like the EU referendum for things all
over the world and it's it's just it
makes it makes you more statistically
literate which is a super important
skill so definitely a more or less and
the other one which is more famous is
Enoch time which is Melvyn Bragg a
journalist talking for an hour to
experts on a particular topic and the
one I just listened to was Sun Tzu the
author of the art of war and each
episode is like a really quite specific
topic although sometimes it's not even
that specific sometimes it's like plasma
which is like 99% or something like that
of the kind of observable monitor in the
universe but basically they're very
professionally curated discussions on
you know specific topics with experts
and they are every week and it's a
fantastic way to just broaden your
knowledge makes you much more aware of
you know kind of what's academically out
there I guess other podcast I recommend
99% invisible which is about design and
kind of a broad sense but super super
like highly produced and actually that
also goes to song exploder which
basically breaks down a particular song
with the that could be the composer or
the sort of singer-songwriter and sort
of look is really track by track this is
how we built it up so to me is a like
kind of pseudo musician I find that
really interesting if you have to comedy
stuff the triforce Vioxx cast is like a
very niche thing you have to kind of
know the people for it to be funny but I
really like it my dad wrote a porno is
probably the funniest podcast I've ever
listened to you which is for those of
you that don't know a guy's dad it
turned out that he'd written a porn like
a like a novel and it is terrible and
the podcast is the guy's son and his
friends reading it out and sort of just
reacting to how bad it is and it sounds
like a terrible idea for a podcast but
oh my god is it funny here okay
now it's time for me to use the vlog is
my secret motivational weapon because
what I really need to do something I
know that if I film myself I'll actually
stick to doing it so I need to write
this video which means it's time to film
me writing this video
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I've been writing for quite
a while now the scripts much further
along than it was I have basically I
mean the scripts by the nature of the
video it's split between special and
general relativity right those are the
two theories that are at play here going
through that mathematically and
reminding myself of what I did it Oxford
was really really fun it uses
mathematics that I hadn't used anywhere
else and it produces this theory which
is just so beautiful that I may have
already added to my Amazon cart a
textbook on general relativity the one
that I use which is Rindler special and
general relativity which I thought was a
fantastic textbook but I think I'm gonna
have to buy it for myself because I want
to get fully engaged with this again
because just just giving for the
Wikipedia articles to be like yeah okay
I remember this yeah the metric you know
determines the Christoffel symbols that
determines the you know there's like a
chain basically the the takes you from
the geometry to the actual physics and
just like reminding myself of those
links and having to do these things in
the exam and I was like I just want to
get back into it like I just yeah don't
get me wrong I love that mysteric
physics and I'd love working on my PhD
but I definitely missed some other bits
of physics now I'm gonna go for a drink
in town with some friends CID take time
off just not enough
[Applause]
[Music]
so Alex I was asked to recommend some
podcasts this episode who do you know of
any good people what it's gonna say hey
wait I don't know what you mean
psychology there's a link below do you
think anyone can tell with massive nerds
we can eat son what yeah oh that's just
the stuff mine broke just those on the
bag there just there's some healthy
veggies this thorough and this and this
oh yeah
some broke this is the second shot this
week
this is b-roll transition footage so
it's much later after the gym earlier I
did a whole bunch of cooking I actually
sorted out my meals for the next five
days longer than actually cuz I'm going
away but five days worth of meals which
are now in the fridge or one big batch
of cooking so huh it's done don't think
about food for a little while and now
I'm back at work on the script which is
taking so much longer than I thought it
would I think this video is gonna have
to be laid by a couple of days which is
a great shame because I hate being late
I hate getting failing to meet deadlines
I may have just been a bit too ambitious
with this one this is just saying to
learn from your future
I just don't think doing for science
videos or for kind of feature videos a
month is feasible I think two is more
realistic and then putting more stock
into making those ones better and to
making the vlogs better just just kind
of redistribute in how I'm spending my
time so tonight's job is to finish off
this script I am NOT gonna be filming
later because I am so tired you know
what surprise I went to the gym earlier
but I I am white
I think we have to be a job to Sunday
morning recording except Sunday there's
yet more gym because we're really
hitting it hard
[Music]
alright so you join me relatively late
in the day I came down to Exeter this
afternoon when it's the gym this morning
with Alex I would have filmed on the
train talking about what it's like to
come out to external number time to
taking this journey but uh it was so
ridiculously crowded I just couldn't
there were nine of us and a little bit
between carriages because there were
more people than seats we are doing the
livestream tonight which is a test
it's choral complan which is kind of a
short service but we're testing out a
new live streaming setup because I've
basically been playing around with some
software it's a new hardware and then
tomorrow has the real reason I'm down is
we're live streaming Handel's Messiah
which is quite a big deal and not
entirely sure it's gonna work but here
we go some more I've also got a meeting
with my supervisors to talk about the
extra Corrections I'm doing to my my
thesis
look quite nice to see them actually
it's been a little how and then as
discussed on I think Thursday also get
me sitting down my friend penny to talk
about her experiences as a being a
student by accident so that's going to
be the next work
[Music]
so well I don't know what you mean don't
sleep watch the walk and find out so
long time they'll be sure the next one
of a shorter such a lovely you are
very the wiki cast okay so we heard he
drinks at the pub and now I am back this
you might recognize this room this was
the room where I stayed when finishing
my PhD this is a basically a spare room
I'm Emma Michael's house so I'm sleeping
here for the next two nights and that's
the end of the week so tomorrow I mean
we're doing that Chapel livestream we're
gonna tweak a few things based on
tonight but that's gonna be happening
got that meeting next week I don't even
know I need to get that
faster-than-light video out as soon as
possible this blog is going to come out
there's two more videos I might make
that just one video it's gonna come out
next week as well but also there's that
talk tomorrow with my friend about BME
experiences a texture so that's going to
be tomorrow for me next episode for you
so that's the end of this video thank
you very much for watching do tune in
next time for all that extra stuff and
yeah thank you for watching maybe next
time I work out what the hell to do with
this PhD
[Music]
[Music]